[Music]
Willie Mays changed the way the game was
played
he is the most spectacular baseball
player that ever played
none of them could do what Willie Mays
could do you had to experience it to
understand what he meant
he was baseball
dominated the entirety of the game 660
home runs 12 gold gloves he put out over
7 000 baseball players playing center
field
when it was the leader in our team I
wanted nine guys on that field to play
together once we play together we can
win watch them get it Willie took all
the black athletes and held them on his
shoulders
here's Willie Mays the first great
African-American Superstar to show the
world that baseball is changing San
Francisco accepted him as a athletic
star but not as a person they want to
live next door to he could not buy there
he stated I'm going to make changes by
going out and being the greatest
baseball player that I can be
the epitome of Willie Mays was the
famous catch in the World Series 30
yards went to 40 yards a little further
and he makes a miraculous package he
stops a step short of the wall that
catch is one of the greatest athletic
performances in sports history
right now to even try to explain to you
how much I love baseball
I think we have what you call a love
affair
there goes Willie Mays
greatest player to ever play this game
hey you Willie Mays the greatest
baseball player of all time
[Music]